You identified my husband as a significant micotoxin.
So what are micotoxins?
Micotoxins are toxins from mold.
So, does the current programs you have him to run,
each of you include addressing these micotoxins?
Or should his weekly program be updated?
Or run addition programs to deal with the micotoxins?
You're inside would be appreciated.
So, two things can take place if you're dealing with micotoxins.
You can.
So, understand, a micotoxin is not a living organism of mold anymore.
It's a toxin that a mold produced.
So, all these different types of mold can produce toxins.
So, you could have a sensitivity to the organism, the mold itself.
That's typically an immune reaction to the mold.
So, that's what's called an IgE reaction.
So, you know, you go into a moldy building and you start coffee.
You go, oh my gosh, I just can't handle this moldy building.
I got to get out of here.
That's, that's a sensitivity to the mold organism.
So, that's what you could run the rife for to help kill any mold organisms.
But a micotoxin is a toxin that the mold produced.
So, it's not a living organism.
So, there's really not rife programs to do.
Because remember, the rife works best on killing things.
So, you could run mold programs on the rife.
And really for when you have, you know, a current exposure to mold,
it will help kill mold in the house.
It will help kill mold organisms in your body.
But it won't kill micotoxins because micotoxins aren't living.
So, you have to detoxify micotoxins.
You have to killate micotoxins.
You have to use different nutrients that will grab onto micotoxins
and hold them out of your body.
So, a micotoxin is not a sensitivity.
Micotoxins are poisonous to everybody.
So, it has nothing to do with your genetics.
Micotoxins are toxins, they're poisons.
They're not organic, not living, not, they're not organisms.
They're poisons.
They're chemical poisons that a mold will produce.
So, you're not really running the rife to kill micotoxins,
because micotoxins aren't living.
I'm going to throw it at that point.
You have to killate those out.
You have to grab onto those.
You have to use that diet.
You have to use different detox supporting all your detox pathways to get rid of micotoxins.
So, not, there's not really a change in programming.
The only thing that I would say that you could,
there could benefit you with the rife with micotoxins,
is running liver programs to help with detox.
But there's that, that is already in each of your night program.
I put those in there.
Or running the ion foot band, the ion pro wave.
So, ion pro wave programs will help pull things out of your body.
They're mainly intended to get the higher frequencies in you,
but they're certainly like the clear line detox ion pro wave program will help detox out your body.
Other ways to get rid of micotoxins,
with homeopaths with different keylators, like I said,
supporting all your seven phases of detoxification using the sona,
doing coffee enemas.
Anyway, you think about getting rid of like a heavy metal,
or getting rid of glyphosates, or getting rid of poisons in your body,
or your toxins, is how you get rid of micotoxins.
So, micotoxins, when you do a micotox test by mosaic labs,
you do that.
It's measuring the toxins from past exposure,
or could be current exposure, but it's typically past exposure.
But you do have to look at current exposure.
That's why it's good to get your house tested.
Do we have live in a moldy environment?
And by many times people will go, yeah, I remember.
I worked in a really moldy environment several years ago.
Well, that could be what was the exposure.